[Music]
you are partnering up with positively
fearless it's a movement for a really
important cause
yes it's a movement to introduce and
educate people who are black and gay and
bisexual in that in that community and
create awareness about HIV because it is
like definitely impacting our community
stronger than it is a lot of other
communities I'm very passionate about it
and positively fearless and I are very
excited about the movement that we're
making I think that people what we can
do is sometimes people we think that
until something affects us that we can't
be involved and I think that even as
someone who is HIV negative what what I
can do is use my voice my platform to
create awareness to inspire and
encourage people to go out get tested
you will be healthy and the people
around you will be healthy and you will
be equipped with the knowledge to know
what to do with your body to keep you
safe I want to know if you've got a
follow-up cooking for straight out of
hog I am I'm going to New York tonight
actually after I leave here you know
because I couldn't miss my date wouldn't
miss it but I'm flying to New York to
start working on it tomorrow I'm going
to I'm so inspired in New York by saying
Broadway shows and live entertainment
and I have a lot of stuff that's on my
heart that I really want to put into
this album and I wanted to just like
knock straight out of Oz out of the park
so I I think that I have a really great
concept and I'm really excited for
people to see it
you have so many amazing collaborators
on Austria oz yeah dream dream guest
stars on the next record oh my gosh I
would love to work with Nicki Minaj
there's so many artists that I really
really love and of course I would love
to work with Taylor one day Taylor okay
and do you think she'll return the favor
I think it's time right who knows it
could happen when they add things she
loves me and I'll and I love her and II
think she's an amazing artist so it'll
happen when it's meant to be
[Music]
you